[Музика]
давайте
покінчимо з бідністю Резюме Alviso mismo moines ia ілюструє
собор мадрид резонанс
гепарда настрій ключовий момент наш SES
відновився, але нерухомий
гітарист Nova зараз бутик дуже багато
[M monopodic rigna  ]
привіт, мене звуть Ольга магма, я
вчитель англійської, ласкаво просимо на наш сьогоднішній урок,
і у нас є особливий гість,
вітаю Алена привіт, Ольга, приємно бачити вас
знову так приємно бачити вас знову
дякую, що приєдналися до нас дякую, як справи
сьогодні у мене все чудово,
хоча я мало спав минулої ночі,
добре, зайнятий підготовкою до уроку, а що
з тобою, я чудово, дякую, дуже
схвильований, тому що тема нашого
уроку дуже близька до того, що я роблю, тож
давайте йти  так, давайте зробимо це
дуже добре, що ви думаєте про цей
твір мистецтва, чесно кажучи, я люблю робити подібні
фотографії, і так, мені подобаються
такі речі, які красиві,
вони мають гарний смак, які саме, я
б добре, щоб це було з Інтернету  я був
Шукаю картинку, яка б
символізувала мистецтво, і коли я побачила цю, то
подумала, що це та, яку я дійсно
хочу використати на сьогоднішньому уроці. Я
радий, що вам подобається,
так, я радий, що вам подобається чудово,
чому не  ми почнемо з невеликої вікторини
добре мистецтво давайте почнемо з картин
сьогодні дуже добре, у мене є дві картинки,
і питання в тому, хто намалював це, о
Боже, один іспит правильно, а суть так,
Гаррі,
твір мистецтва, але деякі люди кажуть, що
це погано  подивитися на цей дивовижний мод,
тому що в ньому є якась енергія, як-от
неправильна енергія, це також добре, супервідомий
так, ви можете сказати, що деякі люди вірять у
будівництво, якщо люди вірять, що вірять лише
одному, мені потрібно сказати, що я не
знаю і
ніколи його не бачив
ще раз, я ніколи раніше не бачив це,
як посередині посередині, і
він трохи маленький, але я можу здогадатися, хто
проводить ці зустрічі в
такому стилі, так,
а зліва насправді красивий
мій улюблений, але я
не знаю  з художником, напевно, я
погано знаю, я дуже схвильований, що це
буде не тільки урок англійської мови,
ми будемо вивчати багато нового про мистецтво
, але художники та художники, яких ви знаєте, я
люблю виправляти помилки я вірю в це
моя місія виконати твою місію так, я
сьогодні на місії
дуже добре, ти сказав мені правду
про картинку посередині з великою кількістю
графіки, яка була ідеальною, ні, ти сказав, що
ти сказав, що я ніколи цього не бачив, я
так.  так що я ніколи не робив
так дуже добре я ніколи цього не
бачив так я ніколи цього не бачив
так все добре дуже добре не забувайте
презентувати ідеальний ви повинні включити
прямо зараз будинок дуже хороший я ніколи
його не бачив  перед правою правою
правильною добре, давайте ви готові до
відповідей правильно так Террі Найт Вінсент
Бург дуже добре, а як щодо Таємної
вечері
добре, Таємна вечеря так, мабуть,
те, що я думав добре, ви знаєте, чому я
думав, що Мікеланджело, але це не
так,
і ви  напевно пам'ятаєте з
попереднього уроку де  чи можемо ми побачити
Таємну вечерю в Мілані так це саме в
Мілані так добре дуже добре а
як щодо сина людського чоловіка чоловіка
з яблуком так
так дуже добре правильно а що щодо
відомих українських митців красивих так
майже
Марія так так  Я чув про неї дуже
не знаю, що це її картина так
її картина так Марія према чанко
Казмір мій Левич я так я розумію, що це
було добре,
що змусило вас здогадатися, що це все
це геометричні фігури куб моє бачення
так так дуже добре
і крик і крик так
едвард мама так так гарно дуже добре
давайте спробуємо згадати хоча б
назви картин вінсент ван гог
тільки назви картин так історія
ніч остання вечеря син людський
бик український ти гармата бух  так перше
слово так Супермен розлютився композиція
композиція і крик дуже добре
хто той
український бу так і той
посередині на Тайній вечері відмінно
ми a це дебіл тест добре зроблено як
наш сьогоднішній л  esson є останнім, що
охоплює тему мистецтва, ми будемо робити
деякий перегляд на всіх попередніх
уроках, і один з уроків, які ми
переглянули та найпоширеніші типи про те, як він
класифікується, це
візуальне, виконавське мистецтво та прикладне
Еліна, в якій групі ти виступаєш так,
так, Меган, давайте подивимося,
які види мистецтва у нас є у вашій
групі, добре, це танці, це співи в кіно і
театрі, і це дуже гарна музика,
коли ми говоримо про картини,
яким буде мистецтво  рожевий, я думаю,
це візуальне, так, це дуже добре, яке
інше візуальне мистецтво ви любите після
малюнків, це фотографія, фотографія,
так, дуже добре, і останнє, що ми
ще не виявили, прикладне мистецтво, що
це, ви можете прочитати це, так це
архітектура  модний дизайн дизайн
інтер'єру та вироби з дерева так, звичайно,
їх може бути набагато більше, але це
основні, тому який з них буде улюбленим, якщо
ми говоримо про прикладне мистецтво, я вважаю, що
дизайн одягу хороший, я заохочую  кожен,
хто займається мистецтвом, ви завжди можете вибрати
час, коли я зустріну когось, хто каже, що я
не дуже цікавлюся мистецтвом, і я кажу,
яке мистецтво таке величезне, подивіться навколо,
там так багато видів, які добре зроблені,
так, і тепер ми"  я буду вивчати ще
деякі фактичні перегляди для тих, хто
продовжує спостерігати за нами, і трохи нової
інформації для вас, Еліна, правильно
картини, добре, ми можемо знову класифікувати
їх як пейзаж, який малюнок
буде для мене
пейзажем, ландшафт Ланге може бути першим  і
другий, і, мабуть, ні, але якщо я
буду доглядати за краєвидом, для мене це
другий з гірськими горами і
ця прекрасна природа навколо дуже гарного
натюрморту, це той з рибою, я
повинен вам сказати, о так, більше все ще
живий я, тому що  це реальне життя, ви
знаєте, тримаєте все ще дуже добре
портрет Мерилін Монро так, дуже добре, а
що щодо картини, яку ви
запропонували з морським пейзажем, це
третя, яку ми бачимо праворуч
відмінно
і та  e шматок пляшки жовтий шматок
і, ймовірно, перший, який ми
можемо побачити дуже добре, чи можу я попросити вас
прочитати п'ять слів ще раз пейзаж
натюрморт портрет морський пейзаж шматок пляшки
дуже хороший, тому у нас є два
втечі, так, морський пейзаж
і пейзаж, тоді у вас є
зображення натюрморту і битви, мир
відмінно, так що перший
про мир, другий це пейзаж,
третій портрет морського пейзажу
з Мерилін Монро і натюрморт
добре виконано, дуже добре, ми  готовий
продовжити так чудово,
добре, добре, скажіть мені, якщо ви знаєте цю
картину, так, звичайно, у мене навіть є її
копія в моєму домі, дуже добре
, це на полотні, чи вона надрукована на папері
вдома, у мене є надрукована на папері
дуже добре
в рамці так в рамці дуже добре я
люблю Фріду Кало Еліна
я так щаслива, що у вас є ця фотографія,
тому що ми збираємося подивитися на цю
вигадку, насправді навчимося
описувати картину дуже легко. У мене є план,
який допоможе  ти т  o опишіть будь-яке
зображення, яке ви бачите, добре правильно, давайте
подивимося на план, який у нас є, добре, чи
можете ви прочитати ключові повідомлення на
ньому, щоб ключові повідомлення, щоб я міг сказати, що я
почну з середини посередині мм-хм
на передньому плані так  чому б нам просто не
прочитати це і не перейти прямо до зображення, щоб
посередині у нас
була людина, її звуть Фріда, і на
передньому плані ми бачимо деякі не листя,
але я не пам'ятаю, як це сказати
слово чи можете ви мені допомогти
підпис угорі є неба
та листя красиве зелене листя і
кілька бджіл і метеликів і
фон ми бачимо її красиву тут
з цими метеликами зліва ми
бачимо мавпу, яка грає зі своїми
планами, так, а внизу  ліва
рука
може бачити її насправді
внизу ми бачимо її білу футболку або
що це таке так, це те, що я
можу сказати за планом так, план дійсно
допоміг вам продовжити, не згадати
основні особливості кращого, що я залишив на
передньому плані  так, на передньому плані і
на задньому плані, на передньому плані, на
задньому плані повно листя, так,
природа чудова дуже гарна, і ти знаєш, на
що перше, на що ти звертаєш
увагу, коли дивишся на цю
картину, звичайно, для мене це її шия,
яка  трохи кровоточить, це
те, що мене приваблює, і
ця картина, звичайно, я звернув увагу
на цих тварин навколо неї, вона любить
робити такі речі, щоб додати деталі,
і це іноді містичне, іноді
трохи темно, але в цьому випадку це  сповнена
природи, сповнена позитивних емоцій, так,
і, звичайно, її зовнішній вигляд завжди серйозний
її стиль її власні фотографії
так автопортрет автопортрет
майже більшість картин Фріди Кало або
автопортрет автопортрет  rtrait це дуже
добре, а
як щодо емоцій, які ти відчуваєш,
коли дивишся на цю картину, я відчуваю, я
відчуваю біль, звичайно, як завжди, ймовірно,
на її фотографіях, але відчуваю позитивні емоції,
що вона щаслива сама по собі,
навіть з цим болем з цими
тваринами  з цим усе навколо, ніби
вона досі щаслива, хоча в цьому світі
так, але вона серйозна вона зосереджена
зосереджена дуже дякую, вона
зосереджена дуже добре відмінно
дуже дякую, ви коли-небудь
бачили оригінали
музею MoMA, які я бачив, але я б хотів
одного  день, щоб піти на чарівну виставку, щоб побачити її
велику виставку, яка, звісно, є в ц
ому місці в цьому музеї в Мексиці, чу
ово. Я колись бачив статтю про її
удинок, який повернувся до музею, ви
ожете побачити предмети, які забувають ко
ір  використовувала, коли вона жила там, ви
можете побачити живі речі, які її надихнули,
так, і, звичайно, це яскраво, це
яскраво-блакитний, повний зелені, і
природа добре, ми готові рухатися далі
так, відмінно  Не добре, що велике завдання на
сьогодні для всіх, а для Аліни
насправді є тренування наших навичок письма
. Серцем будь-якого іспиту зазвичай є написання
сьогодні, ми збираємося писати
неформальний лист, які типи
виступів ми можемо мати, якщо я скажу неформальні,
що  було б, ймовірно, це буде
деяка інформація так офіційні листи так
так офіційний лист,
коли ви пишете директору вашої школи, коли
пишете скаргу, але сьогодні
добре знати,
так сьогодні це неофіційний, головне
в неофіційному листі  ви
пишете своєму другові, тож ваш стиль може
бути дуже приземленим, ви можете використовувати
гнучкі сленгові слова так і інформацію,
яку я вам дам, ви можете використовувати
скорочення,
як тут, тоді як неформальний лист ви
повинні уникати  коротше, ви вважаєте, що вам
потрібно уникати сленгу, і ви повинні бути дуже
формальними, але вам пощастило, що сьогодні неформальний
лист, давайте подивимося на завдання, яке ми
будемо писати, а потім офіційний лист, давайте
подивимося, що він пропонує нам
зробити  magine ви нещодавно були в
художній галереї мм-хм, вас просять
написати електронного листа своєму другові, щоб
описати це в офіційному електронному листі в офіційному
листі, будь ласка, не забудьте згадати
все, що просять у завданні,
включно з тим, коли ви туди були
добре, що вас вразило і
чому ви порекомендували своєму другові,
добре,
якщо ви напишете це на іспиті і
пропустите деяку інформацію, яку вас
попросили зробити, на жаль, у вас
нічого не вийде. Не забувайте
включати її завжди  повернутися до свого завдання,
коли ви виконуєте вправу, навіть якщо
ви її зробили, прочитайте своє завдання ще раз і
переконайтеся, що ви включили всі
пункти в завдання.
Пам’ятайте, коли ви плануєте свій лист,
формальна неформальна структура есе дуже
важлива, перший параграф  де ви
зазвичай вітаєте свого друга і вказуєте
причину написання, що буде
причиною для написання у вашому листі, я
скажу, що я був у музеї дуже добре
так так, тому причина написати свою
ділитися емоціями так, абзаци другий і
третій, вони включатимуть усі пункти
з тесту, коли і куди ви були,
що це саме який музей і чому,
що я там побачив так, і все
добре, і параграф четвертий завжди не
забувайте залишати простір і час
запропонувати подальше спілкування
попрощайтеся  пишіть та тестуйте, будь ласка,
використовуйте перекладачі, будь ласка, перевірте свою
граматику, будь ласка, постарайтеся зробити так, щоб вона
якомога ширшала словниковий запас, поки
ви відпрацьовуєте будь-яку інформацію, яку
ви додаєте до своїх письмових частин,
важливо не бійтеся
перевіряти орфографію, шукаючи гарне
синонім світу, і
завжди є корисні фрази, чи допоможете ви
мені їх прочитати, будь ласка, так, я
вам давно не писав
мм-хм я не писав  я з вами нещодавно спілкувався,
сподіваюся, що у вас все добре,
сподіваюся, що у вас все добре, зараз у вас все добре
після того, як, однак, на
щастя, у зв’язку з
цим доповненням, орієнтація на
додавання додавання до цього, я з
нетерпінням чекаю на вашу відповідь або на те, що ви добре зробили,
зараз ми  готовий почати писати,
давайте спробуємо добре пам’ятати, я тут, щоб допомогти
вам  це так, звичайно, ти можеш зробити це
дуже добре, тож як би ти хотів
почати,
як звати твого друга, кому ми
пишемо, я напишу своїй подрузі
Міра чудово, ти можеш почати це робити
[Музика]
[  Музика]
молодець Олена дуже хороша
д добре шановні студенти, будь ласка, пам’ятайте, що ви
працюєте над своїми письмовими завданнями, є
кілька моментів, які слід пам’ятати. Пам’ятайте
стиль, чи то неформальний, чи офіційний
, це важливо
Олена, ми повинні завжди уникати скорочень
та флангів, коли це офіційний лист чи
добре виконаний сьогодні ваш лист був просто
ідеальним  для друга, це було дуже
дуже круто, дякую, дуже дякую,
а тепер інше, будь ласка, контролюйте
час самостійно дуже часто вам
надається ліміт часу, будь
то 25, 30 чи 40 хвилин, ви самі сказали час
і перевірте, щоб залишити деякий час  для
виправлення орфографії та для того, щоб побачити, як ви
можете покращити свій текст, це може
бути додавання деяких прикметників, додавання деяких
сполучних слів, як ми мали сьогодні на дошці,
однак, на
додаток до цього права, ви можете побачити
посилання в нашій сьогоднішній презентації
та  також, будь ласка, пам’ятайте, що завжди
перевіряйте, залишайте час, дайте
собі приємну перерву на дві-три
хвилини, а потім прочитайте це ще
раз  читання дуже важливо, ми будемо
працювати з іншими письмовими завданнями на наших
уроках, продовжуйте спостерігати за нами, і
велике спасибі всім, хто приєднався до нас
на сьогоднішньому уроці до побачення
[Музика]
la siguiente bullet Емма
О сьогоднішні токласи О, Колумбус, оливка,
ти чилі сопресата листинг
джерело вологості для Murata було
зроблено, що чоловічий рівень всесвіту сенатор
Кріс впорався з високим тоном у
Ryman інформативність є проблемою завантаження
Whatcom відкриття важливо це
контингент tetra bonitas він зібрав
один лондонський онлайн-викупителя Cosna
бідність відновити це блакитний
прекрасна тепер з Недом Лія буде запечена у
вас трицепс qualia Мадрас
[Музика]
ви